sie sagen doch eigentlich dass die
fleißige in diesem Land gemolken werden
das ist auch gut so weil die man kann ja
nicht eine magere Geiss melken sondern
nur eine fette ja das ist ja normal und
irgendwie also ich beklag mich noch
nicht mal dafür dass ich Umsatzsteuer
Mehrwertsteuer Lohnsteuern Soli und Gott
weiß was perückensteuer und alles
bezahlen darf ja es ist okay ich bin
irgendwie wie heißt Workaholic ich
arbeite auch noch gern manchmal bin ich
morgen zum vierfach und Arbeit bis nach
zum 12 Uhr wunderbar aber wenn ich dann
sehe wie das verschwendet wird ne in
diesem Schwarzbuch was gerade wieder der
der Bund der Steuerzahler Schienen ist
wenn es vernünftig wäre ja ich würde
sofort wenn ich auch bestimmen könnte wo
meine Steuern hingehen ich würde sie
sofort an die Arche geben weil ich mir
echt ich kenne die Arche in Hamburg ich
kannte sie nicht und ich weiß was die
dafür eine gute Arbeit leisten ja und
ich weiß auch um die Tafeln und und auch
wenn ein Joghurt abgelaufen ist dürfen
die denn gar nicht mehr nehmen ich weiß
dass man noch zwei schon länger essen
kann und es denn auch ja also es ist
alles Quatsch es sind auch Einzelfälle
aber eins weiß ich auch das ist
statistische Jahrbuch hilft auch nichts
ich habe in der
abitur-mathe Wahrscheinlichkeitsrechnung
und Statistik gehabt mein Leben ist
keine Statistik und nur weil ich keine
Kinder habe ja habe ich wahrscheinlich
mehr getan für diesen Staat wie manch
einer der ein paar hat das wollen wir
auch gar nicht bezweifeln aber Frau
Obert sie sagen die Verschwendung sucht
der Politiker ist schuld was stellt sich
am meisten es ist nicht wirklich möchte
ich sagen Verschwendung sucht für mich
ist ein Problem wenn jemand Geld im
großen Stil zur Verfügung hat für das er
nichts getan hat und wenn alles schief
geht hören wir da auch nicht
sanktioniert dafür ja also meine
Minister in diesem Land
ich will wirklich behaupten leider dass
die nicht mit dem größten Sachverstand
gesegnet sind nicht die so
Wissenschaftler und Leuten mit Professor
Dr die haben wenigstens Fachgebiete
erarbeitet ja und ist es glaube ich
manchmal gar nicht die war Küchenhilfe
ist jetzt Minister ist ja auch nicht
schlimm ja ich mache jetzt machen wir es
einmal konkret am Tisch wohin Gelder
Fliesen wofür die ausgegeben werden wir
fragen jetzt einmal Herrn raphaelchen ob
es ihnen ein Beispiel einfach wo sie
sagen da wurde Steuergeld jetzt mal
wirklich verschwendet
das gibt das Schwarzbuch der Bundeswehr
Steuerzahler gibt ihnen hunderte von
Beispielen wie konkretes ich kenne zum
Beispiel eine schöne Brücke bei uns im
Freiburg die steht da aber es ist keine
Zuführung und keine Abführung dieser
Brücke da und sonst steht sie darum also
das scheint offensichtlich nicht eine
besonders vernünftige Ausgabe gewesen zu
sein wir haben sehr viele sagen wir mal
sagen wir mal Kindergeldzahlungen zum
Beispiel an Kinder die gar nicht da sind
wir haben wir haben alles mögliche an
fehlausgaben wir haben viel
Investitionen obwohl wir gar nicht als
Staat mehr viel investieren da kann also
nicht mehr so viel schief laufen weil
die Investitionsquote ja nicht mal nicht
mal im Bett da ist in der Stadt
investiert gar nicht mehr aber der Punkt
ist der wir haben viel viele
fehlausgaben aber das was wir wirklich
diskutieren müssen ist
der Glaube ans Kollektiv der Glaube dass
das kollektives richtet wir hatten das
vorhin ja diese diese dieser Glaube ist
ein Irrglaube das Kollektiv ist es nicht
wir brauchen im Prinzip die individuelle
Eigeninitiative wir brauchen die
Unternehmer dann ist es nicht
der Staat der Arbeitsplätze genau das
wollte ich sagen nicht der Staat der
Arbeitsplätze schaffen es ist
erwirtschaftet er muss mit dem Geld der
anderen Wirtschaft kann man sogar so
weit gehen da würde ich Herr Kistler
gerne mal fragen mit Blick auf das
britische Berlin ist der Staat ein
schlechter Unternehmer der Staat ist ein
Unternehmer am pseudo-unternehmer mit
schlechten Gewissen also es ist immer
die Rede vom Staatsgeld aber ist
natürlich das unser aller Geld das
Steuergeld der Staat erwirtschaftet
nicht er mischt sich allerdings in
wirtschaftliche Prozesse ein so dass
diese oftmals zu ihrem Nachteil
ausschlagen das ist glaube ich das
Problem er hat sehr sehr viel Geld sehr
sehr viel Gestaltungsmacht wir sind kein
kein reiches Land würde ich sagen wir
haben in ein Land mit einem reichen
Staat und einem gar nicht so reichen
Bürgerschaft also das muss man schon
auseinanderhalten und das Problem ist
glaube ich einerseits dass wir a dass
sie Verantwortung mit dem Ausscheiden
aus dem Amt abgegeben wird das ist schon
ein Problem also man kann ich dann
nachträglich noch sagen was in diesem
Etat falsch gefallen ist das sind die
schon in der Landwirtschaft halten
Vorträge für teures Geld und das andere
Problem ist dass wir zu einem Staat
geworden ist der die Gesellschaft nur
noch als Summe unverbundener
anspruchsberechtigter Gruppen begreift
das heißt wer gerade den Mund laut
aufmacht der wird momentan ein bisschen
zufriedengestellt was ich mir als
kleines Beispiel nehme immer hier in
Berlin läuft aber ich wohne haben wir in
der Nähe drei Schulen die gammeln alle
munter vor sich hin in einer Sporthalle
darf man nun auch gar keinen Sport mehr
betreiben weil ich glaube ich zu kalt
ist das kommt was von der Decke runter
und zwischendurch wird allerdings für
Millionenbetrag ein Fahrradweg
hergestellt mit einem grünen Belag damit
man offenbar also wie in ein Moosfeld
wenn man dort einen Unfall hat das war
eine Ausschreibung das musste teilweise
aus dem Ausland herbeigeschafft werden
also ich möchte mal sagen überspitztes
formuliert Marmor für die Fahrradfahrer
und geballten gebrochene gebrochene
Holzpaneelen für die Schüler und das da
läuft einfach etwas verkehrt man hat
verschiedene Töpfe die werden
unterschiedlich gefüllt und das große
Ganze Gerät aus dem Blick die denken
alle nur an die nächste Wahl das ist
doch klar
ja weil wenn da nicht kopierung ist und
es bringt 5 Millionen
rein und die vielleicht auch so machen
Statistik ja also ich habe ja vorhin
gesagt und dass ich keine Behauptung
sondern es ist einfach Tatsache dass wir
die höchste sozialausgabenquote haben im
Moment den größten Sozialstaat den wir
jemals haben es gibt noch mehr
historische statistische Highlight wir
haben wir haben seit jemals wir haben
gleichzeitig die höchsten
Steuereinnahmen nicht nur absolut
sondern auch relativ zur
Wirtschaftskraft noch nie war die
steuereinnahmenquote des Staates so hoch
wie jetzt gleichzeitig haben wir mit den
höchsten Steuereinnahmen die wir jemals
in unserer Geschichte gemacht haben die
höchsten staatsverschuldungs
voluminat die wir jemals gemacht aber
schauen wir uns das nochmal so besonders
effizient kann der Staat mit seinem Geld
nicht umgehen
ganz klar dass wir ganz stark aufpassen
müssen was die Politiker mit den
Steuereinnahmen machen und das werden
wir versprechen das versprechen wir hier
bei